he is uh the head coach of my uh west
point cadets he is uh jeff monken who
joins us on the program coach
good morning thanks for joining us i'm
looking at the schedule
you guys are playing uh tbd a couple of
times uh
your favorite against tbd a few games
here
what is the update on your schedule
we're going to open against middle
tennessee state here
uh the first weekend in september and uh
we've kind of got a schedule planned out
from there i don't know that i'm at
liberty to
to uh to say all the of the games that
we've we've kind of scheduled and got
agreements with but
we're we've got we've got a full
schedule we're excited about that and
and anxious to get to that first one so
that we can continue on through
uh would it be fair to say that you're
speaking to power five
conference teams about maybe getting a
game or two
we have we have spoken to power five
teams i i will say it's it's
that that's a bit of a challenge just
fitting into the uh
conference schedules with them we had
some agreements with
with some teams that uh from conferences
that are still playing
um so we we've been able to maintain
those uh but it's been a challenge
we've got a great staff here that's
worked really hard to to put a schedule
together
the the most important thing was for for
us was to
to get games to be able to to play a
schedule and
give that opportunity to our our student
athletes why are you able to play
football in the big ten and pac-12 can't
i can only speak for for our our team in
our school
uh our our our institution has done an
unbelievable job of of testing
and uh treating and and protecting all
the folks that
that live here and work here and go to
school here we've we've got all of our
cadets back
uh as for our football team we came back
june 1st which was the first opportunity
uh
to return uh the ncaa allowed us to
start voluntary workouts then and
we had uh some positives on the way in
guys coming from all over the country we
haven't had a single positive test
since then so uh maintaining i guess the
bubble that they talk about
we've been able to do that here and and
do it very effectively so proud of our
guys and
and just uh very very thankful to our
administration for giving us the support
that we need
is your cousin still the offensive
coordinator at georgia he
he is as far as i know i don't think
kirby's gotten rid of him yet
but have you talked to him because the
sec feels like they're the nfl
it's full speed ahead and they're
planning on playing football what's your
brother
uh said about that oh he he's uh
he's working like i am at getting that
team prepared and we don't talk
uh every day but we we did talk earlier
in the summer and
and uh i think their their attitude is
the same as ours if we can do it safely
and uh and and maintain the health of
our team
that we want to play and i don't think
there's a lack
of desire for the teams in the big ten
or the
pac-12 or even the commissioners and the
presidents that everybody wants to play
it's just finding a way to do that
safely will there be fans
at west point i'm not certain exactly
what uh that's going to look like we're
hopeful that we can have
uh at least our cadets uh that that come
to every game
and uh and then hopefully some fans as
well but that's to be seen
that would give you a little bit of a
home field advantage if you had the
cadets there
i mean maybe not a lot but you know
that'd be
a lot more than most of the schools
you're going to be facing it'd be more
than none that's for sure so
they do a good job too they they like to
yell and and uh
and and get excited over there so we
enjoy having uh the core cadets there
behind us
can you sneak me in for one game i don't
want to sit next to anybody but my wife
and i usually go
once a year if not every other year and
you know what i'll do i'll be the pa
announcer how's that
you're you're in we'll put you on full
scholarship oh whoa
yeah but i don't want to go through the
uh the rigors of being a cadet up there
because that's not
you you're already qualified
well good luck with this and uh are you
sure you don't want to give me uh
any nuggets here that you know who you
might be playing
well we're still intending to play the
academy games and uh
tulane was on our schedule uh
originally and we're gonna still play
them in uh in november
uh there was a at georgia southern um
they they put out uh publicly that that
they had scheduled a game with us
in in november that's obviously my my
former school i was a coach there
before coming here to army and and uh
so i think some of those are public i
just i'm very cautious about
about putting those out there until our
administration our
athletic department is is uh is
is willing to kind of say here's what it
looks like and i understand that like
did you talk to your brother about
scheduling georgia
uh we we talked to everybody in the
country that would have a conversation
with us about a game
we we were when when things started to
fall apart
in terms of the schedule and and the
conferences
we we reached out to everybody bob
bretta who's uh one of the senior
associate athletic directors here
handles scheduling and i think he talked
to all
129 other teams in the fbs and just said
hey
are you interested in doing this so i'm
sure we probably had a conversation with
them
and and uh and everybody else in the
league what's the coolest thing in your
office as i uh look
there at the bookshelf so i've got a lot
of game balls and stuff back there my
my favorite piece i got a picture right
over my shoulder here my dad
is uh is catching a touchdown pass for
illinois state against ball
state in 1960 and uh a one-handed catch
for
for a touchdown which is a a treasured
memento
i've got here he still comes all the
games and stands on the sideline with us
he's my high school coach and
so that's that's pretty neat how about
you you got a lot of stuff in there
i got i got so much stuff in here um
i have a couple of uh army navy helmets
that they send to me every year when you
guys play
like a promotional helmet um
i have jerseys i have army uh jerseys in
here
uh i have so much stuff in here coach
like it's
it's kind of crazy that this is i can't
call it a man cave
like this is a man field house because
it's there's a basketball court here
football field golf simulator
pinball two bars grilling area
come visit coach i i need to you come to
west point it sounds like it sounds like
it's
a pretty fun place to hang out we can do
a home and home here i love visiting you
guys
up there but uh we'd love to have you uh
during safer times come visit us
agreed we'll send you the contract thank
you coach good luck
thanks a lot be navy all right yes all
right there you go jeff monken he's the
army head football coach